I might wear a suit for like you know
just kind of a nice occasion
most of the time I'm just you know
fading a nice collared shirt if I'm
doing anything like this I'm in board
shorts in Hawaii so let's try a suit
what do you think yeah okay awesome
you could probably rock it you know
walking down the street wherever middle
of the day this might just be that
introduction into that it's funny
because since I was always getting like
boxes from you know one sponsor I kind
of just would you know anything I got I
would just try to wear them all through
and luckily they all had you know it was
all really good style of it I have so
many t-shirts that's unbelievable
already for fashion night I think it's
you know you have to look good you can't
just only be I think one one sided and
so that's I kind of wanted to be a
complete person so this is like already
cool experience to kind of already learn
because then I can actually know what
I'm talking about like I don't have that
understanding just because I never had
to really go to shop everything was
always like shopped for me you know not
only you know try to be a great athlete
but like you know feel to show show my
best self always you know cuz it's easy
to do it on the water since that's my
job
takes a little bit of confidence to wear
a skin-tight wetsuit but wearing a good
suit like this gives you a lot of
confidence